welcome to FIFA 15 Ultimate Team or fut
as we like to call it this year we have
taken the mode to a whole new level with
fresh features such as concept squads
friendly Seasons Lan players and more
the New Concept Squad feature is a
powerful Squad planning tool that allows
you to plan future squads using the
entire F player catalog use it to plan
your next transfer market buys find
replacements for players and test out
different chemistry combinations and the
best part is that you can share your
squads with friends or or copy and
comment on their squads via the EA
Sports Football Club Newsfeed keep score
with friends in the allnew friendly
Seasons mode challenge your friends in a
1 V one version of The Fan Favorite
Seasons mode and track your stats win
Seasons to earn the current title holder
position and the bragging rights that
come with it ever wonder what it's like
to have Messi on your team pre-order the
FIFA 15 Ultimate Team Edition and get
the chance to play with him as a lone
player with Lan players you'll be able
to try out some of the most sought after
players by signing them to a club on
loan using the E Sports football club
catalog you can sign loan players for a
limited number of matches to see how
they fit in your team before pursuing
them on the transfer market to get
started all F fans will get a loan
player when they built their first Squad
in FIFA 15 any additional loan players
on the market can be found in the
catalog and acquired using football club
credits and finally exclusively on Xbox
we have more than 50 Legends to choose
from look out for football pits of
yester year such as alen Shir Peter
schmeichel Kosama and many
more FIFA 15 Ultimate Team lets you feel
the game this is your chance to show the
world that your squad is the ultimate
team if you want to get up to 40 fot
packs make sure to pre-order the
Ultimate Team
[Music]
Edition